[Music]
alright first of all let's just loosen
this thing up and can we pop some
bottles I want to pop bottles with crazy
rich Asians okay come on grab it there's
another bottle down there so I mean
let's start the party right we're in
Vegas and there's no way we're gonna sit
here
[Applause]
get in there get in there get in there
celebrate so what does it mean because I
was reading statistics that it's been 25
125 years since there's been an
all-asian cast in a movie which is
bananas what does it mean to have this
movie and make this movie I think I mean
it's it's insane to think about it's
long it's there is cinema there is
agency coming out of Hong Kong China
there's never sort of english-speaking
agents all around the world we've got
the UK from Southeast Asia these guys
Americans do you think about 25 years
that's an entire adult life that went I
grew up without seeing representation
in hurlan his or her life and so this
movie answers that question and it's
about time I think and now that's a
great movie and hopefully we make a lot
more so it's one story representing a
whole yeah open the gate you know you
talk about the diversity the accents and
all the differences like black people
have the same thing where it's like
you're from the south you're from you
know English but it's kind of cool all
the different accents and we get to see
the difference between an American and
someone who grew up in Singapore which
is crazy I didn't really understand that
there was that big of a difference
well no but in the movie he grows up
right okay in the movie he grows up in
Singapore tell us a little bit about the
movie and how crazy it is in his role I
mean just to give you a like I am the
cool as an effective quite a lot of the
hassle for Rachel her character Nick
comes from an extremely wealthy family
and that's where all these fine ladies
come in it's that they're the crazy
cousins or they're crazy best friends
and he just comes from this world which
Rachel just isn't prepared for she and
and that partly is Nick's father you
didn't prepare me I'm a middle-class
girl
who doesn't understand all the crazy
rich stuff that he grew up with and then
she's my best friend there's a bestie so
she her character kakeland
he's also crazy rich so she's kind of
like my fairy godmother thrown out the
crown but she's nouveau riche so my
friend
yeah she's new money and so that then
you see dirty old money new money and
you also have a crazy edge don't you oh
I have more you mean the wave yes you
know didn't expect that immediately
buddies by the way this big summer for
you this movie and oceans right tell me
about the text chain then all you ladies
were on oh my god like is it so it so
they confirmed the text chain is that
long well you know I mean it's late I
can say that you know what I mean but
also like there may not be one like you
know I mean that's what I'm trying the
audience is just they don't hack yeah
but yeah yeah there may be better now
you two ladies are two of the ladies
that are horrified that your guy is
marrying this woman right
ask you it is she's actually although
she's she's it comes from incredible
wealth she's very down-to-earth she and
she could be the only member of the
family close to and she actually
welcomes Rachel and we have some lovely
scenes together actually because
Ashley's going through her own kind of
marital troubles that kind of mirror you
guys a bit and yeah they bond over that
yeah and I say IRA mentally who's the
bride
Nick Young's best friend so the wedding
that Rachel and Nick are coming to and I
I'm not
I'm kind of so okay and happy in my
position in
[Music]
Rachel problem with my character is I'm
so kind of caught up in what's going on
and fair enough so because it's my
wedding I don't notice what's happening
behind the scenes
[Music]
machan it looks like that in the trailer
by the way you got shot in some crazy
places what was it like the location and
some of the things you got to do while
you're shooting we we kicked off in
Malaysia I think we all look throughout
that to do a lot of the interiors
there's a scene where the girls have a
bachelor party or bachelorette party and
some tsarevets
from Islands beautiful by the way you're
not a movie star you were like I've seen
the Instagram post - I've seen it all
you know having having such amazing
company with such a distinct different
careers from
sort of like leaven it's and we were
such a close-knit family and I was able
to kind of lean on that run and sort of
ask the questions that needed to be
asked but it still didn't stop me from
sort of just crapping myself okay great
I need a vacation and I mean he was Nick
Young he really embodied the character
and did a great job
you played a rich guy the core the story
is his the love that he has for this one
her character Rachel and that just
overpowers any of this from
about at its heart is
whether it's rich culture middle-class
culture or like Singaporean culture and
values which are very different from
rachel's working classes
and so I mean each project first off
good and crazy rotations because like
taught me something about myself and the
community so it's really good okay tell
me something crazy rich Asian you have
done that goes on in your life and will
let everybody
tell me something that
I wrote an inflatable couch moments in
that like hour we were filming that we
would how long I'll ahead so we would be
pulled around this inflatable couch
[Applause]
swept away screaming her mouth off just
in the min Lucas this ocean is fantastic
science that was the craziest thing
alive
your line
[Music]
and the trailer
how are you prepared for that you know
but I'll you know they're just good I
feel like the world we get sick of me in
like two months I don't know you didn't
you know they never know I not prepared
at all but also it just just got to be
here you don't see anything summer for
all of us we talked about this briefly
but this is a trilogy
three books so what we see three movies
[Music]
everybody goes to see the be glad to see
the movie guys see the movie I don't
know II don't want to jinx it I also
want the clothes well that was
definitely a difference for me from
fresh off the boat ride Rachel
because I wear mom clothes and went flat
shoes and that I was wearing ball many
different they were that were harder to
wear in crazy protections but it was
super fun because we had such fun
colorful vibrant choices
the biggest problem with the beautiful
clothes three-piece suits filming in
Asia where the hot seat for me I got the
pajama I wish you would step out you
just need to wrenched throughout the
entire day throughout the entire evening
and we had these really beautiful set
pieces entire soldiers but the family
urn there's about 150 extras there was
no air conditioning at that point and so
there was just like a steam tell me
about your wrapping okay she only had
one eye so you always you know when
she's looking at you so cute
she got throughout coma and then a
cataract that got so big that you I had
to take it out such a big charity didn't
sorry well yeah so now it just looks
like she's sleeping on one side would
you look at you she turns no and you're
like oh I see you're looking at me with
your eye
she's brown she's her mother laughs
she's really very affectionate when she
wants to be and she would skyrocket
hey what's your name hey rabbit I should
make an Instagram account I have it
should we start today right here right
here
this is also a science is your first
movie this is like real University Press
and go round were you on the other side
of the camera cause this experience I
mean we're sort of just picking on we
were on Ellen the other day
yes that was phenomena it's like I've
grown up watching and I think we all
have and just sort of being on the couch
in front of all those those people
talking about something we're so proud
of I mean it just blends all together
and you know more about us has been
fantastic and lining up this amazing
really to get the word out that that
we've arrived in this movie to be
massive each also are the cover
[Music]
what's that what does that mean to you
like
[Music]
why but also the diversity then shows
that stress and really costumes and it
was my first big cover I'm sure many but
it was I think it was he was he was
served far in advance the lonely that
that that was the first bit along the
press and the fact that people were
peeking Amin before any footage was
coming out before anybody had sort of
like seen what we've actually created
they entrusted us enough so I kind of
put us on the front of that I was blown
away and that just shows how much faith
the industry has in our movie the movie
comes out of the walk-in it's a long way
we feel like you've been waiting forever
for this movie to come out I thought we
were just we were just anything yeah
it's a busy since man that it's yo time
is flown
I want I do wanted to come out now you
know but tell me I gotta let y'all go
let's take this bomb Oh
[Music]